let's go to our next caller from the
two-three-four area code caller from 2 3
4
who's this what's on your mind today uh
that mean that is you who's this
my name is s I'm from Ohio what's going
on Seth um
I feel like it's almost like the first
two people that you answered alluded to
what I'm about to ask but it's kind of a
big question okay um the first caller
said something about how people are kind
of like stuck in the primaries and stuff
like that and I try not to let the fact
that Trump is president get me down like
I know that and the other colors just
answered like voting is very important
even if you feel like maybe it's a lost
cause but I guess my question is like
how do we not get so depressed when
thinking about Trump this president or
how do we knock this so like down about
all of the corruption and money in
politics like what can we do about a lot
of that like what can every day people
do to change those things other than
maybe just voting right so listen
definitely check out my video about what
forms of activism are effective from a
couple of weeks ago I don't want to
rehash the entire video but let me deal
with the depression part of it I hate to
make this argument because I feel like
it is just it's depressing to even have
to make this argument about being
depressed about the state of politics
but the most important thing that got me
reactivated when I was sort of in the
doldrums of this disaster that is the
Trump administration was that if I
self-select
out now it's going to get worse and it's
an unfortunate argument to have to make
and some of us might be thinking how
could it possibly get worse this really
seems like we've hit rock bottom but if
the people that are disturbed by what's
going on are depressed out of the system
so to speak it's only going to get worse
so it is critical that we not abandon
the political process at this time
voting is important public
demonstrations being in touch with your
elected officials
locally even when there is not a
national election I've talked about
civil disobedience general strikes check
out my video about activism but that
this is the worst possible time to
self-select out mm-hmm thank you David
all right thank you appreciate the phone
call didn't know if there was a follow
up there but I appreciate the call